yeah my my streams actually blew up in
Korea oh really like the last time I did
was a cooking stream and I was like
making pasta or whatever just talking
drinking wine and someone posted it on
Naver like they took gifts of my of my
stream and posted it on Naver and then
like 20 other websites and Korea posted
it and it just got like hundreds of
that's what it is to be a pretty person
did I tell you that if I did a cooking
stream nobody watch that [ __ ] dude
cooking food I don't know what it's like
to be pretty dude sometimes mad like
it's like it's so funny because I I
always clown my friend Gio about this
year so we were having this like
heart-to-heart conversation and she's
just like yeah you know like people were
kind of talking about like stuff that
they went to when they were a kid right
and she goes yes you know like a lot of
people thinks it's like you know you
know pretty girls get it the easiest and
I just go oh my god but you know it's so
interesting because the world does treat
pretty people way differently and you
know we see the good side but there's
also that bad side too just because you
know that jealousy factor is so [ __ ]
huge because they'll say some [ __ ] like
on the lines of oh she's pretty but I
bet you she's a [ __ ] yeah she's pretty
funny because I always see this quote on
Facebook that's like Oh best friends
you know when best friends talk I can't
remember [ __ ] right now but basically
along the lines of like best friends now
would look back and say oh when I first
saw you I thought you were a [ __ ] kind
of thing they're like oh yeah that's so
funny I'm just like no like I was
friends with someone not like best
friends are good friends but we were
becoming friends and we you know we were
at the bar drinking one night and she's
like going off about like yeah when I
first saw you I thought you were a [ __ ]
like all this stuff like I didn't wanna
even talk to you and I was like [ __ ] you
you don't even know me what kind of
person are you you're just gonna hang
out with you anymore it was like I get
it but like I mean she was just going in
on it you know and I was just like
because a lot of the things you know
[ __ ] we're gonna wrap this bad guys okay
but you know the way
think so let me just tell you the story
about in college so when I was in
college know when I had a girlfriend my
first year do you be fat kid whatever
but I I don't know what it was about the
way that I grew up like yeah I [ __ ]
like looking at pretty girls and [ __ ]
whatever my you know fat ass fat titties
whatever you know normal aspect yeah you
know teenage kid but something about
even the way that I was raised or
whether it was because the way my mom
raised me the way somebody looked didn't
really as much as other people affect
how I treated somebody right and it was
just because I think I I started to grow
up and realize when I was a kid um I
when you're younger you you'd like to
hang out with people based on how they
make you feel or the the social currency
that you get from yeah right so I'm in
this group I become the cool guy makes
me feel good whatever slowly I you know
probably when I was like 17 or so I just
started saying [ __ ] that [ __ ] I don't
need that stuff pretty much yeah I just
want to be around good people no matter
if they were different if they were
dweeby nerdy some of them were thugs I
just wanted to be around people that had
my back time right and so because of
that I think I had this mentality of
look a [ __ ] what you look like who are
you as a person yeah so there was this
chick she was uh she was like a high
school cheerleader or whatever one and
this one went to UCR and weird the dorm
my number one anything she was that
[ __ ] cute but she had a really nice
body I think that's why everybody [ __ ]
with her right so every time she'll walk
into a room guys come in how are you
doing today you know I mean like oh and
every time she says something that
wasn't even [ __ ] funnier you know and
you know I had a girlfriend who I
thought was the world to me so I could
give a [ __ ] life matter so one day we're
chilling you know in the dorm we're all
hanging out and she just looks at me and
she goes why don't you like me and I was
like what what do you I don't dislike
you yeah she was yeah you don't like me
and I'm like so you you kind of like
just walk by you don't really like talk
to me or anything like you talk to
everybody else and I was like no I talk
to you the same amount as I talk to
everybody else I don't know what you're
talking about there's people I talk to
more because they're my I'm growing
closer to them like we connect but I
don't what I don't get what you're
saying I'll say well give me a give me
an example she goes well like yesterday
like I was in I was in the hallway you
know weird
I said hide you you said hi and you
walked by and I was like yeah so what
did I do
yeah right she was nothing you just like
don't really talk to me and I'm like oh
I know why now it's because you're used
to people giving you special attention
that's why you're used to a guy coming
up to you laughing at everything that
you're saying they just think that
you're the [ __ ] funniest [ __ ] on
earth what you're really not so that's
the type of typical treatment that
you're used to so when I treat you like
a normal person cuz I could give a [ __ ]
less about you and Plus you really
weren't my type you know [ __ ] no ass
so you're not my [ __ ] you know I mean so
for her she she kind of equated me
treating her like a normal person as
somebody who just didn't like her at all
because everybody else was trying to
[ __ ] her yeah you know and so I was like
and then you know for her she's like
well you're like the do any fat guy you
should be fawning over me you know not
really like lady like you and I grew up
differently yeah I mean I grew up around
lady with big tits and big asses like
that's what I like you were [ __ ]
flat-chested little tiny girl that's not
my [ __ ] also you're kind of a [ __ ] I
think like that's where sometimes that
that that [ __ ] attitude comes in
because there are girls like that who
are used to being treated a certain way
that when they don't receive that type
of treatment if they feel funny about it
right and it sucks too and there's also
this other like flip to it where
sometimes girls when they see a pretty
girl they they want to be that girl
mm-hmm right and so when they when they
see you they automatically be [ __ ]
because it makes them feel good about
themselves they go well if I look like
that I wouldn't be like or even though
who you are yeah yeah totally it's just
like when when people like I mean I
guess you know I'm sure everyone has
done it at some point but like I just
don't want to be around that kind of
negativity like people like that they
just jump to conclusions or like go for
shitty things like that so that's why I
cut her off but damn it you just like
slice just like out of my life I don't
look back I don't get it you're gonna
meet a lot of people like that though
even for me to like I think a lot of
people when they first meet me oh that's
kind of my fault though because I I'm
very like I'm very honest and open yeah
a lot of the times I think people get
scared by that and so they kind of an
[ __ ]
actually completely okay with it yes I'm
just saying you're right I'm kind of
right it's just I'm an [ __ ] to you
cuz I don't [ __ ] like you you know
you're just gonna see that a lot okay
yeah I'm just going to be a little bit
more empathetic since now it's like okay
like I could see where you're coming
from why you would think that but if
they're like that 24/7 it's kind of hard
to deal with yeah yeah I'm like I'm
generally really like nice I just was
raised to be polite all the time and
just like you know give people benefit
of the doubt and like I'm always just
Pleasant like I'm always chill and nicer
to anyone like you said doesn't matter
who they look like that's hard though
because like I said from somebody's
outside perspective they see you
you're a very beautiful woman and
they're tall giant you know and it's
it's it's it's daunting sometimes right
like um when Muriel first met Geo the
first thing Muriel said constantly when
we got back home she goes wow she's
really pretty and she couldn't stop
saying it and I'm like oh you keep
mentioning how pretty she is
she was [ __ ] beautiful right but
there's this thing when when sometimes I
feel like when girls see another girl
that's just ideally beautiful it makes
them almost feel bad about themselves
yeah dude there's no like self-esteem
issue for me that